I was stuck in an elevator for two hours
and I had to make the whole time but I
don't blame them because one time I
turned into a dog and they helped me
thank you
short but pointless hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a lawyer and
today we are covering one of my favorite
let's say guilty pleasure movies I have
a soft spot in my heart for ghostbusters
- I know
the first Ghostbusters movie is
basically a perfect movie that being
said gun to my head I think I might
actually watch Ghostbusters 2 instead if
they're both on TV I think Ghostbusters
2 was just on cable more often as a kid
I can probably still quote most of the
scenes from the Scoleri brothers trial
your witness yes so as always be sure to
comment in the form of an objection
which are either sustain or overrule and
stick around until the end of the video
where I give the court scene from
ghostbusters 2 a grade for legal realism
so how further ado let's dig in
- Ghostbusters - now it occurs to me
that you probably need some background
for this court scene in ghostbusters -
there have been a resurgence of ghosts
and slime related incidents and the
ghostbusters are investigating a river
of supernatural slime that is flowing
throughout lower Manhattan in the course
of investigating this river of slime the
ghostbusters have been arrested by the
New York Police for basically drilling a
giant hole in the middle of Fifth Avenue
and causing an enormous power outage for
most of the New Yorkers on Manhattan
so with that preface let's go to the
court scene in ghostbusters -
Gouri begin this trial wanna make one
thing very clear all right so right off
the bat we have some actual legal
realism which is interesting for a
change this is the famous New York
Supreme Court it's on Center Street in
lower Manhattan this is actually the
place where the New York courts deal
with a lot of criminal infractions now
the New York Supreme Court is not to be
confused with the US Supreme Court or
the Supreme Court of many states for
some reason New York is really weird in
that they call the lower trial court the
Supreme Court even though it is the
equivalent of what most states call the
Superior Court or the lowest trial court
the highest court in New York is called
the Court of Appeals for some reason
maybe that's just a bit of trivia that
only I care about but it's a super weird
way for the New York courts to name
their courts and it's very
counterintuitive but it is actually the
place where this particular criminal
trial would probably take place ghosts
don't believe in them either right I
want to hear a lot of malarkey about
goblins spooks and demons we're gonna
stick to the facts in this case the
ghost stories to the kiddies understood
now that is absolutely true that the
courts will not recognize ghosts in any
particular criminal trial that being
said there was a New York case where a
house being haunted was in fact a very
important part of the facts at issue was
called Stan Barsky versus Ackerley where
someone tried to get out of the sale of
a house or particularly purchasing a
house because the house was well known
in the community to be haunted it's set
in really interesting precedent
throughout New York in that because the
seller had not disclosed the fact that
it was actually known to be haunted
whether it was in fact haunted or not
the court in that particular case took
it as true that it was haunted but the
fact that it had notoriety for being a
ghost house was something that the
seller should have disclosed to the
buyer and it allowed the buyer to
rescind the sale and get out of buying
that house so sometimes the existence of
ghosts is an important fact in trials
for the open-minded guy huh yeah they
call him the hammer
and what can we do it's all in the hands
of our lawyer now I think you guys are
making a big mistake Louis
mostly tax law and some pony stuff
occasionally I got my law degree in
night school well that's fine Louis
we've got arrest it at night I love it
Louis Tully the famous accountant from
ghostbusters one who obviously was
turned into a dog and the Ghostbusters
saved him in that particular case went
to law school at night which is a real
thing there are some law schools that
allow you to take night classes it's
usually a four-year degree instead of a
three-year degree that being said you
don't want to hire a tax lawyer to
handle your criminal arraignment it's
just not a good idea get someone who
specializes in criminal law put these
guys away fast and make sure they go
away for a long long time okay I don't
think it's gonna be hard with this list
of charges good very good what what is
going on here
they haven't been arraigned I assume
they haven't been indicted this isn't
the actual trial they're not gonna be
tried and convicted in this particular
thing I think that they were arrested
you know the night before this
particular hearing there's no way that
they can be put away for any amount of
time because this isn't the place where
that happens you have to go through an
entire process the ghostbusters need the
discovery they need to know the evidence
that the prosecutors have against them
the only thing is gonna happen here is
that the ghostbusters are gonna enter a
plea of not guilty and then they'll be
released on bail because there's no
reason to put them in jail pending trial
so nothing more is gonna happen at this
point
violating a judicial restraining order
willful destruction of public property
fraud malicious mischief see in a couple
of years at your first parole hearing so
okay so apparently there was a
restraining order against the
Ghostbusters given what happened in the
first Ghostbusters movie that sort of
makes sense but the funny thing that the
DA said here which probably most people
are not going to catch is that they are
being indicted for criminal mischief in
New York tampering with someone's public
utilities is a violation of the criminal
mischief statute under Section 145 0.15
its criminal mischief in the second
degree it is
so funny that they actually got the
exact crime for what they did here
someone really did their research on
this Your Honor ladies and gentlemen oh
the audience
cheeri and there shouldn't be a jury to
call my clients frauds okay so the
blackout was a big problem for everybody
okay okay it's crazy that this is the
criminal trial you see this a lot in
dramas and comedies where they just skip
all the procedural stuff but it really
seems like they skipped a whole bunch of
stuff and went straight to the trial
notwithstanding Lois should probably be
talking to the jury if there is a jury
present at this time and not to the
judge you guys know that it's clear he's
playing the fool here he's an accountant
and sometimes he's the keymaster vince
clortho keymaster of gozer but he is
absolutely not a very good criminal
attorney I was stuck in an elevator for
two hours and I had to make the whole
time but I don't blame them one time I
turned into a dog and they helped me
thank you
short but pointless very good Louis
short but pointless I know this is a
terrible movie but my friends and I will
quote this movie all the time it's such
an iconic version of a criminal trial
among lawyers I think this is right up
there with the Chewbacca defense mr. fee
Anela
please look at exhibits a through F on
the table over here do you recognize
this equipment yeah that's the stuff the
cops took from their truck okay do you
know what this equipment is used for
I don't know catching ghosts maybe I
don't know may I remind the court that
the defendants are under a judicial
restraining order that strictly forbids
them from performing services as
paranormal investigators or eliminators
okay so a couple of things are going on
here which is interesting number one I
suppose that she could ask the question
of the witness whether he knows what
these tools are for and he can say that
he doesn't know where that it I suppose
his best guess is that they're for a
hunting ghosts but because he's not a
Ghostbuster assuming that ghost busting
is a real thing he doesn't have the
expert opinion necessary to opine about
those things he can absolutely testify
that those were the things that were
at the scene of the crime but he
probably is incapable of offering an
opinion as to what they are now what
this district attorney has done is that
she has taken this opportunity to lodge
with the court a copy of the restraining
order that is against the Ghostbusters
arguably it's sort of improper because
she's not asking a question the witness
there are times to do this sort of
laying the foundation but this is an
issue of law not an issue of fact so
it's a little improper for her to take
the time now because it's not the right
time
now mr. Finnell can you identify the
substance in this jar marked exhibit F
yeah that's the stuff all right Your
Honor I've been working on the ground
for content for 27 years
I never saw anything like this in my
life hmm whatever is down there they
must afford it there no we did objection
sure so if Lewis tell he was a good
lawyer he absolutely would have objected
at that point because while again this
coned worker could opine that during his
30 years working underground he's never
seen anything like this it would be pure
speculation and that would be the
correct objection to make speculation it
would be speculation for him to say that
it was the Ghostbusters that put it
there just because he hasn't seen it
doesn't mean that he's seen a hundred
percent of all the things that are
available beneath the streets of
Manhattan so if I was the attorney I
would have objected I would have moved
to strike that testimony that had just
been elicited and I would have asked the
judge to give an instruction to the jury
that they are to disregard that
particular testimony because it's it's
totally improper so so you were just
trying to help out a help out a friend
who was right who was scared of what was
happening to her when you're scared I
love this there was no evil intended no
malice because you live here when you
live in a place you love it like you do
you don't want nothing bad to happen
because it'll never happen again it's an
isolated incident it's a one-shot deal
objection your honor
what is leading the witness just saying
I'm sure that apid Watchers of this
channel will know what's going on here
again this is this is plate up because
it's totally in
proper it's not that the lawyer is
leading the witness it's that the
witnesses leading the lawyer which is
totally unnecessary a leading question
contrary to popular belief is just one
that implies the correct answer you can
ask a yes-or-no question and it's still
not considered leading because you don't
know whether it's yes or no answer that
being said if you say if an imply that
the answer is yes that can be leading so
the way to get around that is is very
very simple you just simply ask what
happened what happened next what did you
see how did you feel these are
open-ended questions that would allow
Louis to allow Peter Venkman to just
give his side of the story that's really
what direct examination is there's no
reason for Louis to be making a speech
here he's not supposed to be making any
kind of statements it's supposed to be
the witness and all he has to do is ask
Bank men what happened next and why did
you do this I think the the writers of
the show know what they're doing because
it's so clearly ridiculous I'll ask you
again dr. Venkman why were you digging
the hole and please remember you're
under oath there are some things in this
world that go way beyond human
understanding things that cannot be
explained things that most people don't
want to know about that is where we come
in so what you're saying is that the
world of the supernatural is your
exclusive province and it's totally
improper for the district attorney to
walk to the jury and then walk directly
to the opposing witness who especially
who is a party that bailiff who is
standing right next to Peter Venkman
should really intervene and get the
district attorney away from the witness
both for the witness's safety so that
the district attorney doesn't attack him
but also for the district attorney
safety so that the witness doesn't
attack her these things can happen and
there's no reason for the district
attorney to be that close it's totally
improper and you know things go bad the
bailiff will tackle one or both of them
Kidon I think what I'm saying is that
sometimes happens someone has to deal
with it and who are you going to call
okay wait a minute there's no jury you
can see on the far right-hand corner
that there's no jury in the jury box
who are they conducting this criminal
trial for Peter Venkman Raymond Stantz
Egon Spengler stand up yeah you too mr.
Tully find you guilty on all charges I
think that the judge here has said some
things that show some particular bias in
California at least when you get a judge
that you don't particularly like you are
allowed one peremptory challenge it's
called a 170 point six named after the
statute if you know ahead of time that
the judge is the hammer and he doesn't
believe in ghosts odds are you should
probably bounce that judge and try and
get another one though you're sort of
rolling the dice that maybe the judge
that you get next is even worse or do
you pay fines in the amount of $25,000
each 18 months to the city correctional
facility Rikers Island woof Wow a year
and a half in jail for digging a hole in
the road well I guess they really did
kind of screw up in terms of destroying
the public utilities and causing a
massive blackout throughout the entire
island of Manhattan though interestingly
different varieties of criminal mischief
for criminal tampering do carry with it
different penalties ranging from
misdemeanor all the way up to a Class B
felony your honor
shut up thank you indeed Society Your
Honor this is important you player the
bill ability of innocent people yes sir
be quiet but
Ultra feathers of the law
[Music]
Wow so well it is pretty unusual for
ghosts to be released as a result of the
sentencing from time to time judges do
like to hear themselves talk so right up
until the ghosts were released from the
slime that could be something that a
judge would say at the time of
sentencing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so well the sky Larry brother ghosts are
destroying this courtroom I guess now is
a perfectly good time to point out that
this is a fairly realistic courtroom for
New York I have practiced in the Supreme
Court of New York and this would be a
particularly ornate courtroom in the
Supreme Court it's not totally
dissimilar there would be probably more
paper there would be a lot more carpet
this may be the ceremonial courtroom one
but that being said this courtroom that
the ghosts are destroying pretty
reasonable and exactly the kind of heavy
old wooden desk you'd see for a council
table as they go flying across the room
don't talk to me talk to my attorney my
guys are still under a judicial miss
strange man order that blue thing I got
from her oh god I love that so much
the judicial estrangement ordered that
blue thing I got from her it used to be
the case that you would get motions and
filings it would have called blue-backed
I think that doesn't really happen as
much now especially now that we've gone
to electronic files for most of these
things but that being said back in the
day you would absolutely have certain
pleadings and filings that were blue
backed using blue paper and if you saw
earlier in this court seen the judicial
restraining order was actually covered
in a blue back which was probably
accurate for the time you know it's been
a couple of years since we used this
stuff
nope it still works it should Power
Cells have a half-life of 5000 years
there's no time for a bench test heat
them up I hate this shot right here
where God looks it's so weird this is
weird the way he looks alright now it is
time to give Ghostbusters to a grade for
legal realism so god I love this movie
so much I know the movie is not nearly
as good as the original Ghostbusters I
will try and be objective but man that's
just a great scene it's just great so on
the one hand you have the Ghostbusters
dealing with the actual Criminal Code
that they probably would have been
charged with had this been a real life
event they were a hundred percent guilty
of criminal mischief for criminal
tampering so the writers got that
absolutely right and the events took
place at the correct courthouse the
Supreme Court of New York in a courtroom
that looks pretty reasonable for what
you'll see at the Supreme Court and it's
possible that the sentence that they
were about to receive before the Scoleri
brothers were released was accurate that
being said the timeline is completely
wrong they skipped over all of the
initial hearings and pleadings they were
never arraigned they never were released
on bail the arguments that were going
back and forth we're totally wrong all
of the courtroom proceedings were
totally incorrect including a lot of
advice that was shown at the sentencing
so I'm going to give the courtroom scene
and the release of the scolari brothers
and Ghostbusters to a flat C that I'm
going to raise to a c-plus just because
it is so darn quotable and so frigging
awesome now if there's something strange
the neighborhood you're obviously going
to call the Ghostbusters but if you're
going to make that call you might as
well save a few hundred dollars at the
same time ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider with ting you
only pay for the actual data and
services that you use at the end of the
month and because you're only paying for
what you actually use ting customers pay
on average just $23 per month for one
device there
no contract overage fees or other
carrier tricks you just pay a fair price
for the talk text and data that you use
up every month and ting has
award-winning customer service because
they don't have any brick-and-mortar
stores they pour their resources into
their phone support if you have an issue
give them a call and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being not a phone
tree and they also offer support through
chat email social media and discord
which my fellow kids say is totes seats
yo with ting you can use almost any cell
phone including the newest iPhones and
Google pixel phones and you can use the
same phone number you're using right now
and ting provides great LTE coverage
because it uses both the t-mobile and
Sprint networks so even if the FTC
blocks their merger you can still get
the benefit of both so sure there are
some people who should pay $200 per
month for unlimited data but if you're
surrounded by Wi-Fi all day long you
might be paying hundreds of dollars per
month completely unnecessary team gives
you the option to pay for only what you
use and if you go to legal Eagle ENCOM
you can use your latest bill to compare
just how much you would save and legal
eagles will get a $25 credit by going to
legal eagle ENCOM that could cover the
entire first month of use and since
there are no contracts you can try it
out for a month no strings attached
again all you have to do is click on the
link in the description or go to legal
eagle ENCOM and you'll get a $25 credit
for whatever service you want plus
clicking on the link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
grade for Ghost Busters to leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reactions over here
including my reaction to South Park and
SpongeBob SquarePants so click on the
playlist and I'll see you in court